let not your heart be troubled you
believe in god believe also in me
in my father's house are many mansions if it were
not so i would have told you i go to prepare a
place for you and if i go and prepare a place for
you i will come again and receive you unto myself
that where i am there you may be also and whither
i go ye know and the way no thomas saith unto him
lord we know not wither thou goest and how
can we know the way jesus saith unto him i
am the way the truth and the life no man cometh
unto the father but by me if he had known me
you should have known my father also and from
henceforth you know him and have seen him
philip said unto him lord show us the father
and it sufficeth us jesus said unto him
have i been so long time with you and yet hast
thou not known me philip he that have seen me
have seen the father and how says thou
then show us the father believeth thou not
that i am in the father and the father in me the
words that i speak unto you i speak not of myself
but the father that dwelleth in me he doeth the
works believe me that i am in my father and my
father in me or else believe me for the very
work's sake verily verily i certain to you he
that believeth on me the works that i do shall he
do also and greater works than thee shall he do
because i go unto my father and whatsoever
he shall ask in my name that will i do that
the father may be glorified in the son if he
shall ask anything in my name i will do it
if you love me keep my commandments god is good
and all the time happy sabbath everyone i welcome
you to the house of god to worship him in spirit
say it again in spirit and in truth most of the
world from my amateurish observation worship
the god in so-called spirit which means noise
and jumping around and shouting but where
the spirit is not of truth isn't present
the spirit isn't present at all because his name
is the spirit of truth you cannot separate spirit
from truth so if you have what you call spirit
and you do not have truth you must ask yourself
what spirit do i really have when joshua came
off the mountain with moses and he heard the
noise he said to moses there's the sound of war
in the camp for them that was the spirit for them
it was not truth and moses had to identify
no this is not war those are the people
worshiping john 4 24 god is the spirit and they
that worship him must it is non-negotiable must
worship him finish the verse in spirit come
on and in sincerity is not enough god must we
must serve god in sincerity and in truth thank god
for truth truth ultimately is christ i am the way
the truth i've told you many times i believe
the father is truth deuteronomy 32 verse 4
the holy ghost is truth first john 5 6 jesus is
truth uh john 14 6 is the father's truth the son
is truth the holy spirit is truth to be a child
of god fully i must be a child that loves truth
nice to see you you look very nice in the outfits
god has given you say amen all right for those
of you online i can't see you but i know you look
nice as well thank you for joining us wherever you
are god bless you beyond your imagination i really
mean that for the family members at born again and
at fmc first missouri city god bless you and
we know the spirit is the same wherever he is
i want to jump right into the message because
we have quite a bit to do today but before i do
i would be remiss if i did not recognize anyone
who is not a seventh-day adventist first in this
building is there someone sitting before me who
is not a seventh-day adventist raise your hand
ah please stand please please stand good
morning how do you do it is a delight to
see you tell us your name chrissy chrissy nice
name that sounds like christ good name chrissy
where are you from pasadena california oh no joke
okay all right chrissy who invited you chrissy
ah you have a good friend chrissy may the
lord bless your life bless your family and
grant you the desires of your heart say amen for
chrissy christie you may be seated god bless you
nice smile who's next did i see another
hand a hand threatening to go up no where
all right just do that so i can see who the
person is oh please stand please good morning
how are you good to see you what's the name
roger good to see you roger where are you from
baytown all right so you're
home who invited you roger
your beautiful wife god bless your beautiful
wife i agree with you 100 roger i'm glad you
came may the lord bless you but put a double
blessing on your wife do you agree roger say yes
grace glows all right roger thanks for coming
and the lord bless you same and for roger
roger's a nice man what's your wife's name
roger i just put you in great danger i'm
sorry it's all right give us her name again
van der god bless you forgive roger
handsome people don't have good
memories forgive roger all right
anybody else you're not the 7th adventist anybody
else oh please stan please please what's your name
kathy hello kathy where are you from
from baytown and who invited you kathy
your mother-in-law always listen to your
mother-in-law if you want to live long
nice to see you kathy now kathy may the
lord bless you i mean that from my heart
guide you direct you keep you from the dangers
of life say amen for kathy my dear sister kathy
you may sit hello no no don't sit just oh
your daughter and what's your name caroline
how are you caroline are you a visitor too good
where are you from baytown and who invited you
thank you very much for coming and
may god place a hand of mercy upon you
and never remove it and protect you from
the attacks of the enemy say amen for kathy
you may be seated please please and when i
say what i say i'm praying with my eyes open
anybody else you're not a seventh adventist oh
please please please stand you want it to be the
best for the last i understand it's okay what's
your name andrea hello andrea where are you from
crosby where is that is that in texas it is all
right not too far away okay andrea who invited you
sherry now who's sherry oh way over there thank
you oh you're a busy person thank you very much
andrea god bless you god take care of you and i
want god to bless you so much that wherever you go
you become a blessing to someone else amen for
andrea you may be seated my lovely sister god is
good and all the time and for those of you who
are guests at born again or fmc or wherever you
are you're not a seventh-day adventist mr god
bless you and thank you for joining us in this
service it's now almost 11 30 as i said we have
a long day i want to jump right into the message
uh before i do that let me ask you to do three
little things for me favor number one preserve
reverence concentrate let no one distract you
because in that five or ten seconds of distraction
i may say something god sent for you you
may not need the entire sermon god may
send a message in 10 seconds and you miss
it because someone with good intentions
distracted you favor number two and for those
of you at home preserve reverence where you are
in your homes i know you're relaxed but try to
be reverend favor number two while i'm speaking
pray for me and say lord put your words in
that man's mouth jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9
then the lord put forth his hand and touched
my mouth and the lord said unto me behold
i have put my words in thy mouth and as god lives
i want to speak god's words as simply as i can
and favor number three i want you to think
as you listen don't just swallow what i say
think read the verses i read is he actually
reading the bible verses think isaiah 1 18
come now let us reason together saith the lord the
best reasoning people should be genuine christians
because their reason under the guidance of the
spirit of truth let's borrow heads and pray
dear god we come to you today on this holy day
which most of the world overlooks or ignores
or are genuinely unaware of whatever the case
their god we thank you for having brought the
light of truth to us and as we bow before you
look upon us with favor de god look upon us
with mercy because you love us and because of the
sacrifice of christ if we've offended you forgive
us god remove the offense and grant us more of
your grace as we listen to the words of life
and the words of the bible are words of life grant
us the assistance of your holy spirit that he may
guide us into truth jesus said in john 16 13
how be it when he the spirit of truth is come
he will guide you into all truth guide our minds
dear god and keep us from the track of error that
runs right next to the track of truth father if
anyone listening to me has covered 19 in the name
of jesus who healed everyone who came to him when
he was on this earth removed that affliction from
that person their god father just to be merciful
please heal anyone listening to me who has covered
19. bless the visitors in a very special way and
father for those little boys and little girls who
may be listening touch their minds because
at a little age jesus knew the scriptures
paul says of timothy as a child that has known the
holy scriptures so touch the little minds i pray
and help them to understand that you're pleased
when children give their lives to you now dear
god i pray for this country bless the leaders
father let them to make let them make decisions
that honor your name and are advantageous to
the gospel wherever countries are represented
by those listening bless them to i pray i humble
myself before you speak through me i ask in jesus
name amen go with me to genesis 11 we shall read
from verse 1. genesis 11 reading from verse 1
our subject an emergency call what did i say an
emergency call genesis 11 reading from verse 1
and i read from the king james version
of the bible when you found it say amen
if you're still looking say amen oh you're still
looking it's genesis sister can't be that hard to
find all right genesis 11 reading from verse one
reading from the king james version the bible says
and the whole earth was of one language and one
speech and it came to pass as they journeyed
from the east that they found a plane in the land
of china and they dwelt there and they said one
to another go to let us make brick and burn them
thoroughly and they had breakfast stone and slime
had there for marty and they said go to let us
build this a city and a tower whose top may reach
unto heaven and let us make us a name lester be
scattered abroad upon the face of the whole earth
we will reread verse four this
time microscopically and they said
go to let us build us a city and a tower whose top
may reach unto heaven now this is after the flood
they're clearly thinking if another flood comes
we can we can go into a tower that is so high the
flood will not affect us so let us make a tower
whose top may reach right unto heaven but notice
how the verse ends and let us make us a name lest
we be scattered abroad upon the face of the whole
earth let's establish ourselves as powerful let
our enemies tremble at the sound of our names
let us establish our name now this is important
go to genesis 12 the very next chapter
an emergency call i hope you're concentrating you
look as if you are what book did i say genesis
what chapter 12 from verse 1. now the lord had
said unto abram get thee out of thy country
and from thy kindred and from thy father's
house unto a land that i will show thee and
i will make of thee a great nation and i will do
what bless thee come on and make thy name great
now what did we read in genesis 11 verse 4 you
go back there now don't lose genesis 12 verse
2 we go back to genesis 11 4. listen to what the
builders of the tower of babel said and they said
go to let us build us a city and a tower whose
top may reach unto heaven and let us do what
make us a name we will make our own name now these
are the persons opposed to god now notice why
let us make a surname lest we be scattered abroad
upon the face of the whole earth they did not
want to scatter they wanted to concentrate
themselves into cities go to genesis 1.
genesis 1 her subject an emergency call
i'm happy to see so many bibles nothing wrong
with the phone but a phone is not a bible
it's nice to see so many bibles but if you're
using a phone god loves you too don't panic
but nice to see bibles genesis 1 reading
from verse 26 let me pray again god of heaven
god of truth speak through me please and
restrain my carnal nature in jesus name amen
and god said let us make man how in our image
after our likeness keep waiting and let them have
dominion over the fish of the sea and over
there foul of the air and over there and over
and over every creeping thing that creepeth
upon the earth now in verse 28 god bless
them and god said unto them what be fruitful and
multiply and replenish the earth they were to go
all over the earth and live this was god's
stated desire before he actually made them
then he made them and he gave them
what his wish was or his desire
occupy the entire world spread out listen to
the builders of babel verse 4 of genesis 11.
and they said go to let us build this a city and
a tower whose top may reach unto heaven and let
us make us a name lest we walk be scattered
abroad upon the face of the whole earth we
don't want to occupy the whole earth we want
to concentrate what we have now is the first
national or kingdom-wide apostasy
against god's clearly stated will
now i said kingdom wide why do i see a
kingdom wide let us go to genesis 10.
our subject and emergency call
genesis 10 you read from verse 6.
are you there and the sons of ham were
cush and miserable and fut and canaan
now we have the sons of ham and one of
them is kush now we go to verse eight
and cush begat nimrod he began to be a mighty
one in the earth he was a mighty hunter before
the lord wherefore it was said even as
nimrod the mighty hunter before the lord
and the beginning of his kingdom was bebel and
eric and akid and kali in the land of shinar
that's where nimrod establishes kingdom keep the
word shiner in mind now go back to chapter 11.
chapter 11 first one are you there you may read
with me and the whole earth was of one language of
one speech and it came to pass as they journeyed
where they found a plane where in the land of
shinar this connects chapter 11 with chapter 10.
the leader of those people must have been whom
nimrod you see and the beginning of his
kingdom chapter 10 verse 10 was babel eric
akid khalni in the land of china now what
is the land of shinar go to daniel 1.
daniel 1 our subject is too slow too slow our
subject is an emergency call all right daniel one
reading from verse one
are you struggling to find daniel
you have it okay you have it now
all right my sister is still looking she is
methodical we'll give her 10 more seconds
all right are you have are you there now in the
third year of the reign of jehoiakim king of judah
came nebuchadnezzar king of babylon and
to jerusalem and besieged it carefully
now verse 2 and the lord gave jehoiakim
king of judah into his hand with part
of the vessels of the house of god which
he carried where into the land of china
where did nebuchadnezzar come from china
what's the other name for china babylon
now in revelation who is god's chief earthly
opponent babylon now go back to genesis 10.
we're looking at the roots of god's mightiest
enemy on earth we're looking at the roots
what's our subject an emergency call what
do you think that call is come out come out
genesis 10 verse 8 and cush begat
nimrod he was a mighty hunter before the lord
pause let's look at mighty hunter he began to
be a mighty one before the lord he was a mighty
hunter let's look at mighty one go to genesis 6.
what is a mighty one genesis 6
and it came to pass when men began to multiply
up from verse 1 sorry upon the face of the earth
and daughters were born unto them that the sons
of god saw the daughters of men that they were
fair very pretty and they took them wives of all
which they chose and the lord said what my spirit
shall not always strive with me and pause the
spirit of god does not plead with you forever
after a while he ceases let me say differently
after a while through constant rejection the
conscience ceases to hear that convicting voice
my spirit shall not always strive with god is
love yes but god has limits to our wickedness
he has limits to our continual rebellion
he has limits because if he had no limits
he could be accused of loving rebellion
but he hates it so he wants to stop it and lord
said my spirit shall not always try with man
for that he also is flesh yet his day shall be 120
years now read verse 4 with me there were giants
earth and also after that when the sons of god
came in unto the daughters of men you see you have
a mixed up situation the same bear children to
them which were which became mighty men which are
of old men of renown so we have this mixture of
god's people with the ungodly produced mighty men
when the sons of god came in unto
the daughters of men and they bear
children to them the same became mighty men
which one of all men of right now from this
this uh this union god did not sanction
mighty man now go back to chapter 10.
we read from verse 8 again can't
read it too often and kush begat
nimrod he began to be a mighty one in the earth
here's an example one of these mighty men he was a
mighty hunter before the lord wherefore it is said
even as nimrod the mighty hunter before the lord
he was a mighty hunter not only of animals but of
men that's why he was the leader he led by force
god leads by love and so the beginning of his
kingdom verse 10 was babel what does babel mean
there are two definitions given the gate of god
and what's the other one confusion the gate
of god not being the god of heaven and earth
you could my you might as well say the gate of
gods all the false gods all the false worship
now the tower of babel no one knows has ever seen
it but similar structures have been unearthed they
called ziggy rats and they're tall and they all
have at the top a place of worship worship the sun
whatever else false worship and bible scholars and
anthropologists who have studied have traced all
this false worship on sun worship and everything
back to this time when nimrod set up his kingdom
what have we said the kingdom of nimrod made of
a baby eric akkid calmly in the land of china
this is babylon what was this stated intention
we do not want to scatter all over the earth
what did god say replenish the earth what
we have is organized opposition to god
but it was a worship system you
see the word church can deceive you
this side didn't hear me i said
two mm-hmms from that side nothing
from this side let me try it again
the word church can be deceiving
the word the word gospel when not used in the
context of scripture can be misleading paul
says if any man preach any other gospel
unto you so the fact that someone says
gospel you ought to go study for yourself when
you hear church you ought to go study come on
for yourself because church can mean all kinds
of things there's a church of satan it's a church
the word church from the greek ecclesia simply
means a coming together or calling out a gathering
which the greeks used when they came together as
assemblies to conduct the business of the cities
that was an ecclesia and you know the bible
writers used that word because the word was
familiar to the audience it's just a calling out
but a calling out from what and to what church of
scientology is the church are you following me
cults are churches and so when you hear church
or gospel you've got to be careful when the
israelites were coming into canaan god told
them in deuteronomy 18 verse 9 when thou art come
into the land which the lord thy god giveth thee
thou shalt not learn to do after the abominations
of those nations in other words this the church
behavior was so disgusting to god the bible
describes it as abomination part of their worship
service was live child sacrifices from time to
time and god said in verse 10 they shall not be
found among you anyone that maketh his son or his
daughter to pass you the fire so the fact that it
happens in church does not make it right it has to
be consistent with thus says the lord somebody say
amen and so what we have with nimrod back there
was a religious system and a political system
in revelation let's go to revelation
well before we go to leveling let's
go back to daniel 1. sorry about that
let me redirect you go back to
daniel one let's take a closer look
chapter one
no little chapter two chapter two chapter
two i don't wanna give you too much
but i wanna give you enough are you a
chapter two all right let's bar heads father
as we continue to study a word let the
spirit guide us god and as john 7 17 says
if any man will do his will he shall know the
doctrine give us all a willingness to obey you
in jesus name i pray amen go to chapter
three let's read from verse one chapter three
three three nebuchadnezzar the king made an
image of gold whose height was three score
cubits and the breath thereof six cubits he
set it up in the plane of dura in the province
of babylon now from verse four we said that in
herald cried aloud to you it is what commanded
by whom by whom nebuchadnezzar neduca nazareth
did not oversee a democracy his was a one-man rule
and the bible describes him this way whom he
would he slew whom he would he kept alive it was
entirely up to him he was a cruel man cruel man
yet god allowed him to conquer jerusalem let me
slide this into your consciousness there's nothing
on earth political that god does not oversee
do you think political events just happen
the highest final guiding power is the hand of
god guiding events according to what he intends
understand when you understand that you
don't have to get into fights with people
are you following me let every soul be subject
under the higher power for there is no power
but of god the powers that be are ordained
of god god is in final control daniel 5 17
the most high ruleth in the affairs of men daniel
5 27 the most high ruling in the affairs of men
daniel 5 32 the most high ruling in the affairs
of men and when we understand that as a christian
bible base we have a peace of mind others don't
because our understanding begins in heaven
theirs begin and stay on earth are you following
me so nebuchadnezzar made an image of gold in
verse 4 and then on herald cried aloud to you it
is commanded or people nation languages what does
that tell you people nations languages the whole
world that's the world of the bible the whole
world that at what time you hear the sound of the
cornet fruit harp sack but saltery dulcimen all
kinds of music he fall down and worship the golden
image that nebuchadnezzar the king have set up
who set it up nibiru can answer
now commandment number two
thou shalt not make unto thee any grievan image or
any likeness of anything that is in heaven above
or that is in the earth beneath or that
is in the water under the earth thou
shalt not bow down thy serve to them nor serve
them so we have a clear commandment from god
nebuchadnezzar made the image he required people
to bow to the image now we have three hebrew boys
three seventh-day adventists from way back nobody
said amen i am not coming back to this place
three seventh-day adventists who honored
god's law they were in that crowd
and the herald cried aloud to you it is commanded
let me digress the command of the state cannot
have more weight than the command of god
the command of the church cannot have
more weight than the command of god
nebuchadnezzar commanded but god had earlier
commanded and the command of god
must countermand the commands of men
three boys wouldn't bow they begin as i call them
verse 15 now if you be ready then at what time you
hear the sound of the cornet flute harp sackball
salter me and dulcimer on all kinds of music
he fall down and worship the image which i have
made well in other words idol worship is good are
you following as well but if you worship not
in other words if you disobey me and obey god
he shall be cast the same hour into a
burning fiery furnace and who is that god
they shall deliver you out of my hand now he
was the most powerful man on earth he wants to
know is this someone more powerful than i that
can deliver you from my wrath who is that god
don't tell god that because when
he shows you you won't like it
pharaoh said in exodus 5 2 who is the lord that i
should obey his voice and let israel go i know not
the lord and i will not let israel and god showed
him who he was thomas says leave leave leave
nebuchadnezzar said who's that god
and in chapter four god showed him
struck him he became an animal like creature
for seven years on hands and knees eating grass
the dew falling on him his beard his hair his
nails like an animal seven years until the bible
says he lifted up his eyes and acknowledged god
and god restored his sanity and his kingdom god
to good god say amen god does not hold grudges but
don't challenge god and so he set up this image
and if you read daniel 9 daniel 3 all the way
down to verse 18 or so you'll see nebuchadnezzar
set up the big nazar set up the beginning set
up nibiki nazar set up nebuchadnezzar set up
verse 16 shadrach meshach and abednego
answered and said to the king o nebuchadnezzar
we are not careful to answer thee in this manner
if it be so our god whom we serve that's that's
important whom we serve when when darius threw
daniel into the lion's den he said oh daniel is
thy god whom thou serve is continually it was at
liberty don't just think god jumps in and saves
you while you serve satan this mic isn't working
you can be serving satan and look for god's
deliverance and god's blessings but a lot
of christians do that we are babylonian
lifestyles and we want jerusalem blessings
it doesn't work our god whom we serve question
for you now do you serve god don't answer me
our god whom we serve is able to deliver us from
the burning fiery furnace and he will deliver us
out of our hand o king but if not ah powerful
words don't serve god conditionally if you give
me a husband i'll come to church if you give
me a job i'll come to journey if you get rid
of my enemy i'll come no no no i'll come to church
because you want me to come but if not be it known
unto the o king i love that i've talked about that
very often i like be it known unto thee many young
people in college they don't say to their friends
be known unto thee i myself and the adventist
they hide on the job we don't say that our
colleagues be known unto thee i don't eat pork
i don't drink alcohol i'll do i will not do that
in order to fit in be it known and today i don't
declare myself better i declare myself a follower
of thus saith the lord be it known unto thee
when you let people know you
you save them from confusion
then they're better able to make a choice i want
to follow i don't when you confuse them god holds
you responsible be it not unto the o king that
we will not serve thy gods nor worship the golden
image which thou has settled and so nimrod set up
this system to oppose god's clearly stated will
scatter maybe it has a set of an image which
also opposed god's will now in chapter 2
nebuchadnezzar had a dream he saw an image
but it was made of all gold that was him
no sorry it was made of gold silver brass and iron
feet of iron and clay he understood from daniel
the head of gold was him that's you silver
someone else is coming another kingdom inferior
to thee daniel 2 39 then one of brass the greeks
then iron the romans iron and clay the kingdoms
at the end of the world after the roman empire
fell in 476 he did not like that interpretation
my kingdom will end so in chapter 3 he makes his
own image he doesn't dream about it he makes it
are you with me this is reality now it's all gold
from head to foot god's image he set up as a means
of teaching a lesson only the head is gold in
other words this is god's version of history
babylon middle persia greece rome this is
god's that is god's doctrine that is god have
determined the times before and the bounds of the
habitation acts 17 and verse 26 i believe it is
nebuchadnezzar no i don't like that version
of history i don't like god's version
i'll set up my version this image is all gold he
wanted to say babylon will last come on forever
are you suffering because you serve
god your suffering will not last
forever god will bring believe me god will bring
it to an end when he sees that the training he's
trying to give you is successful the more you
cooperate with god the shorter your suffering is
but some of us have to be taught again and
again and again and again and god wants to
save us so badly he keeps teaching us again every
lesson becomes more painful than the previous one
which means a smart way to deal
with god when he says it do it
and so we have a death penalty in
general um daniel 3 for not bowing
we know the boys were thrown into
the fire god brought them out
go to verse 28 of chapter 3 i want you to see
how powerful god is our subject an emergency call
it is oh 5 to 12. this is probably my longest
sermon i don't leave what chapter did i say
3 of daniel verse 28 let me pray father as
i continue let me be conscious this is for
your glory and your glory alone and for the
blessing of your people in jesus name i pray
amen do you have my version read with me what
does 28 say then nebuchadnezzar what spake and
said blessed be the god of shadrach meshach and
abednego keep reading who have sent his angel and
delivered his servants that trusted in him stop
question for you don't answer me do you trust god
if you do you'll return the tire
who made the trees that was food can
god feed you yes who made the sun
god who made atmosphere oxygen god who made the
water god can god provide for you yes what did
jesus say behold the fowls of the air they saw
not neither do they reap nor gather into barns
yet your heavenly father feed of them he doesn't
say their heavenly father this is your heavenly
father now if your father feeds a stranger why
won't he feed you and no one's listening if your
father will feed a stranger why won't he feed
you oh ye of little faith have sent his angel
and delivered the servants that trusted
in him now read the next statement
come on and have changed the king's word stop
that's not the emergency call i had in mind but
whoever that is please sin no more have changed
the king's word are you with me what
does that mean go to proverbs 21.
quickly quickly quickly who has it who has it a
church full of slow people who has proverbs 21
ah my handsome brother to the right he has it
all right proverbs 21 how about people in the
front have they found it yet no no no all right
sister so you finally found it okay proverbs 21
let's read first one are you there read with me
listen carefully read microscopically come on
the king's heart is in the hand of the lord as
the rivers of water he turneth it with whatsoever
he will stop we will reread microscopically
identifying the persons in that verse now
how many persons are in that verse two name them
the king and god tell me this status god is god is
supreme he's god of every everything
heaven and earth tell me about the king
he rules over an earthly so who's bigger now
listen to this we have the most powerful being in
the universe what's his name god the most powerful
being on earth what's his name king the bible says
the big king can take the heart of the little king
and turn it anywhere he wants so who controls whom
now you live on earth on the earthly kings are
you with me king biden if you're in england
king johnson if you're in china
king xi jinping if you're in france
king macron are you following all these kings
there is a king above who controls all of them
and sometimes god gets them to do what he
wants they're not even aware there's a power
controlling them somebody say a man for god
now let's reduce it to your circumstance as
we continue an emergency call you are on the job
your supervisor is the first cousin to be el zibab
a horrible person making your life difficult
he's a king in the office are you following me
but you serve the king of heaven on
earth can your king control him and
but remember what nebuchadnezzar
said who trusteth in him
whom thou surfaced do you serve your god do
you trust your god god is not an atm machine
we go when it's convenient the king's heart
is in the hand of the lord and so we go back
to daniel 3 28 and have changed the king's word
now go to daniel 7. a subject an emergency call
you know i need 15 more minutes can
i have them say yes all right thanks
daniel 7 what verse do you think
i'll read 25 god bless you 25.
are you there now speaking of a power
called the little horn are you with me
in in thessalonians called the man
of sin in revelation 13 called what
the beast from the sea the beast from
the sea all right read 25 with me
and he shall seek to change speak
great words against the most high
and shall wear out the saints of the most high
and think to change times and laws stop the bible
says there's a power on earth that will think to
change times and law now laws of written things
you know that either on paper or in the head you
know the law here's the power challenging god
go to daniel 2 daniel 2 read verse 21 this is
about god this is daniel just before he explains
the vision of daniel 2 this is his preamble so
nebuchadnezzar understands what's going on verse
21 of daniel 2. what does the bible say and he
changeth the times and the season who is that
the god of heaven and earth who is that power in
725 who wants to change the time the little horn
but the little horn cannot change the
word of god what does daniel 3 28 tell us
god change the king's word what king the
king of the persians whose words never change
the word altarest not in their minds the
laws of the needs and persian change not
but not forgotten he changed darius's word
and brought daniel out listen to me carefully
god rebuked an entire kingdom for one
man abraham he did it more than once
in chapter 12 he rebuked pharaoh for
abraham in chapter 20 he rebuked abimelech
the philistine king for abraham in chapter 26
he rebuked another philistine king for isaac
god can rebuke an entire nation
to defend one of his children
who trust in him and serve him
now go to revelation 18. before we go there now
go to go to galatians 1. let's see how dangerous
churches are it's uh something after 12.
galatians 1 who has to rush off to work can i
see your oh yeah okay okay what book did i say
what chapter reading from verse this read from 13
galatians 1 new testament folks new testament 1
reading from verse 13 come on come on come on
okay all right that's okay read with me for
you have heard of my conversation in time past
in the jews the word conversation there means
conduct or behavior paul says you know how i
behaved in the past when i was a member of the
jews religion that's the church are you with me
that's the church keep reading how's that beyond
measure i persecuted the church of god and wasted
it how many churches in that verse two ah you're
not following me it's my fault listen to the verse
for you've heard of my conversation in time past
in the jews religion i was a member of this church
as a member of that church i persecuted the
church of god stop how many churches in that
verse name them the jews religion and the church
of god which one belonged to god the church of god
but there were two churches
one trying to destroy the other
go to revelation 17.
john sees a vision of a woman in revelation a
woman represents a church either pure church
or corrupt church and is corrupt based on
what he teaches are you with me his doctrine
determines his corruptness or its purity so
we have two women in revelation representing
two churches one in twelve the true church of
god one in seventeen the corrupt church called
babylon in vision john sees something read verse
six of gen of revelation say what's that say and i
saw what a woman drunken with the blood of there
and with the blood of the martyrs of jesus so
when i saw her i wandered with great admiration
why did he wonder do you know what he was seeing
he was seeing a church destroying come on churches
now he'd been accustomed to the roman empire
destroying countries but he's seeing a religious
organization destroying other religious or and he
wondered and the angel said wherefore this
now marvel i will tell you the mission the
woman of the beast that carries her which after
seven heads and ten horns sorry for rattling off
don't marvel but he was stunned
a church destroying a church
but when nebuchadnezzar said
bow that was a religious command
when nimrod set up a kingdom to
oppose god that was religious
and when nebuchadnezzar didn't like the fact
that his image his golden head would pass away
he set up his that was a religious opposition
to god let me put it more clearly for you
who said crucify him
the church
john 1 1 he came into his own his own
receiving not who was that the church
i don't want to depress you but you need
to understand the word church is not always
positive there's a false church and there's a
true church are you with me go to revelation 12.
i have to let you go because too much information
will confuse you but there's so much i want
to tell you revelation 12. say that again take
another week okay uh you don't want me to live
when i get home okay revelation 12 verse 17.
read that for me let me pray for father as i
continue to speak to the people whom you love so
much tell me what to tell them in jesus name amen
read verse 17 revelation 12 and the dragon
was wroth with the woman stop read verse 9
of revelation 12. now concentrate concentrate the
only person who should not concentrate is a corpse
concentrate are you there now reverse nine and
the great dragon was cast out that old serpent
called the devil and satan stopped who's
the dragon satan now go to verse 17 again
well hold on hold on let us all get
there's a family all right verse 17
read with me and the dragon was wrath with the
woman and went to make war with the remnant of
a seed which keep the commandments of god and
have the testimony of jesus christ now notice
notice the grammar and the
dragon was wrath with the women
as a preacher you run the risk of being
politically incorrect if i am politically
incorrect will you be nice and absorb it yes
yes you will the dragon was wrath with the
woman how many women is that one listen to me
carefully satan is most angry with one church
the others don't bother him
church is not a threat to
satan truth is the threat
of those of you online you're still with me the
dragon was wroth with the woman now we have some
identification regarding this woman let's finish
the verse from the beginning let's go on the way
and the dragon was wrath with the woman come on
and went to make war with the remnant of a sea
which keep the commandments of god and have
the testimony of jesus christ let's speak
the first one keep the commandments of god
that's one identifying mark are you with me
are you sure say amen all right let's find
another identifying mark go to matthew 28
matthew 28 and even though i pray from time to
time you must also pray in your own heart say
lord open my eyes to understand what that strange
man is saying pray and ask god for understanding
do you have matthew 28 let's read from verse 18
are you there not yet not yet as usual not yet
are we there now let's read together and
jesus came and spake unto them saying
all power is given unto me in heaven and in earth
come on go ye therefore and teach all nations stop
where did he send them all nations give me
another word for that the whole world which means
if you're looking for the church of god
it should be come on all over the world
and it should be distinguished by its defense
of the commandments of god so we adding pieces
revelation 12 17 one distinguishing
mark the commandments of god
matthew 28 19 is found in all the world now be
patient with me if you are a member of a church
you have one branch in the bay town the
other branch in pasadena and that's it
hmm that's it what did jesus say go where
you know how long ago did he
say that two thousand years old
well let me be more gracious you're a member of a
church you have a branch in canada you have one in
ecuador you have one in north korea you have
one in japan and you have one in siberia
is that a church of god based on no according to
the united nations there are almost 230 countries
represented by the united nations the seventh
adventist church is in more than 200 of them
the only other church that comes close tell me
is a catholic surgeon now i said i may sound
politically incorrect bear with me the only other
church that competes for vastness of influence
is a catholic church but one of the identifying
marks is what the commandments of god
so you've got to go beyond a worldwide influence
now if you open the bible here's the order of the
ten commandments let me pray again father this
is what the devil hates when i talk about your
law defend me and defend us and defend the truth
in jesus name amen commandment 1 thou shalt have
no other gods listen exodus 20 commandment 2 no
images commandment 3 don't take god's name in
vain commandment 4 remember the sabbath day say
amen commandment 5 honor thy father thy mother
commandment 6 thou shalt not kill commandments 7
no adultery commandment 8 no stealing commandment
nigh nor coveting commandment 10 no no bear
false witness commandment 10 no coveting now
listen to the ten commandments in the catholic
catechism it's official document of theology
commandment one thou shall have another god
fine perfect score commandment two thou shalt
make no images it is not in that catechism
it has been taken out are you listening to me
it's not enough to be all over the world
if you don't have truth you're spreading
error all over the world so there's a
benefit to going all over the world if
you have truth there's a tremendous damage
if you preach error to be all over the world
so commandment three and the catechism is what
remember the sabbath but in the bible it's four
now since they took out two no images they were
left with nine how do we get to ten they split
number ten into two thou shalt not covet thy
neighbor's house that's one commandment the
other one is thou shalt not cover thy neighbor's
wife but if you are thinking look at all the
things the bible says don't covet thou shalt not
cover their neighbor's house that's a commandment
thou shall not cover their neighbor's wife you
should go on and say no his man servant nor his
maidsevere nor his ox they should be commanded
for each one this should be about 16 command
only the commandments have been so-called changed
something else was done by that church and god
has people in that church don't misunderstand me
other sheep i have which are not of this fold the
sabbath in their mind is no longer sadly it's
sunday he shall think to change times and laws
in the church council of laodicea
in 364 canon law number 29
christians shall not do their eyes on saturday
but shall work on that day but the lord's day
they shall especially honor sunday became known as
the lord's day but that's not a biblical statement
do not rest on saturday that's a church
command work on saturday rest on sunday god
says work on sunday rest on saturday so we have
a religious organization directly opposing god
i'll show you one other thing commandment 5
in god's version says what honor thy father
and thy mother follow me closely i
wish i had a screen but concentrate
now this right hand represents the bible's version
are you with me because the right hand is the hand
of power and victory all right on the catholic
version because number two has been taken out
number five is now number four are you not with me
yet are you with me number five is now number four
now how are the commandments divided two tables
are you with me on the first table we have the
first four on the second table the next six now
in the bible's version the first four have no
god before me no images don't take my name in
vain keep the sabbath that shows love for god
in the catholic version we have no gods
before me uh images out keep this and don't
no images that's out so we have
don't take now let me think uh-huh sabbath
number four is honor thy father and thy mother
so where is the pope because the pope is the
father in the catholic church the mother is
mary come on where now has that church place mary
and the pope on the side that belongs to home god
mary is considered a savior
what's our subject what's the emergency called
get out this is not harshness
this is life saving get out
mary is an assistant savior you go to christ
through mary listen to hebrews 1 3 don't go
just listen who being the brightness of his
glory and the expressed image of this person
and upholding all things by the word of his
power when he had by himself purged our sins
not with mary or the angel gabriel by himself
purge that i was saying sat down on the right
hand of the majesty on high jesus christ
does not need an assistant to his work
but mary in that system is on table number
one that's reserved that's why the pope
is god on earth the pope is god on earth in
1870 i believe it was a summer in that time
the law was passed making his word infallible
when he sits on the throne of course and if
he's by the beach no but when he sits on
his throne spoke what he says is infallible
god sent a message in
revelation 18 go there with me
i have to stop i have to stop sorry but
decisions have to be made right now this morning
revelation 18 father in heaven as i conclude
do not stop giving me help in jesus name i pray
amen chapter 18 of revelation we'll read from
verse 1. are you there read with me and help
me and after these things i saw and an angel
come down from heaven having great power and
the earth was lightened with his glory come on
and he cried mightily with a strong voice saying
babylon the great is fallen is fallen and has
become the habitation of devils and hold of
every foul spirit and a cage of every unclean and
hateful bird stop now next verse for all nations
come on have drunk of the wine of the wrath of
her fornication the church and the state mingling
together preaching false doctrine for all nations
have drunk of the wine of the wrath of grantation
and the merchants of the earth what the
kings of the earth want have committed
fornication with the and the merchants of the
earth are which wax writ through the abundance of
delicacies now verse this sounds very good the
church you know armada with the state merchants
business everything is fine but notice verse 4.
read that for me and i heard another voice from
heaven saying come out of her might stop are
you god's people you can decide that with god
come out of her in prophecy a woman is a church
whether false or true god says come out of her
my people why keep reading that she be not be
partakers of her sins and that ye receive not of
her place keep reading for her sins have reached
unto heaven and god hath remembered her iniquities
and when god remembers he acts the rest of that
chapter tells of the destruction of babylon read
verse 21 and a mighty angel took up a stone let
the grit melts on a cassette into the sea saying
what thus with violence shall that city babylon
be thrown down and shall be found no more at all
god will put an end to this system of error
that influences the entire world but let me
tell you something it also includes apostate
protestantism in 1500s under martin luther the
the protestant said sola scriptura which is the
bible only there was a council of the church the
catholic council called from 1545 to 1563 it
met on and off they met to discuss how to deal
with the protestants how to stop this personal
reformation that was the main concern why they met
on and off of 18 years what brought the council
finally to an end and overthrew the protestants
a catholic bishop i don't recall his
name he challenged the protestants
here was his argument and he couldn't answer him
you are challenging our authority to change laws
but you keep sunday which we created then
you are actually following our authority
and the protestants had nothing to say the sola
scriptura people had nothing to say because sola
scriptura does not recognize sunday as holy it
recognizes it's the seventh day of the week so
when that argument was made the protestants
had lost it the catholic church itself has
in its written records books honest people
should actually be seventh day adventist
because they keep the bible sample no i'm sorry i
didn't bring it just came to my mind i can find it
and put it on youtube or whatever an honest person
who should act should actually be a seventh-day
adventist because they're the only ones who
keep truly sola script the church has said that
i was in a certain country preaching and i'm
finishing i've said that three times and uh
i offered two thousand four hundred dollars it
was on a college campus four hundred dollars
is a fortune to any college student and uh
to anyone who brings me two bible texts one
the first day of the week is holy two god
changed the sabbath from the seventh to the first
but since they college students they know how to
do research and go do come back tomorrow night
and get your money we came back the next night for
the meeting i said okay i have come get your money
nobody moved so i checked the mic
come and get your money nobody moved
at the end of the service a young
man came to me this actually happened
he said pastor i looked for those two verses i
couldn't find them but can i still have the money
i said you can forget that now he
literally said can i still have the money
i was doing another series in detroit literally
happened and i spoke on the sabbath being the
saturday not sunday it's amazing how people don't
realize sunday is not the same and many of them
are just honest and i offered 2 500 put up by the
church members literally to anyone who brings me
those two texts so a lady who had been attending
she went home to her husband who was a baptist
she said honey we need to do some repairs around
the house this 2500 will just do it give me two
texts let me go get the money she came back
and told me the husband said yeah she said what
she said honey what are you saying there's
no such text she said then why do we do it
you know what he said i was born a baptist
you finish it for me i'll die baptist
couldn't find the text
let me close you see this what's our subject
there's an emergency call from the bible
to all people who claim to love god
to get out of church environments where the law of
god is downtrodden because the law of god is the
very expression of the righteousness of god and
so god says come out of her that's a call of love
and some may say but it's been in the family for
years come out what do i tell my husband come
out because the alternative when christ
comes will be ugly if you do not believe me
you see god in his mercy when jerusalem was
destroyed in between 1866 and 70 the romans came
and surrounded the city then mysteriously they
withdrew during that period of withdrawal a lot
of christians left the city all of them not one
of them was killed in the destruction the romans
came back and you read the horrible conditions
that fell upon that see people were eating people
mothers would make agreements i'll eat your son
today and you eat my son tomorrow because they
rejected the law-giver jesus christ does the law
save you no but the law is an expression of what
jesus saves you to are you following me if i
save you from sin i must save you to something
and sin is a violation of god's law a righteous
life is a life in harmony with god's law that's
why we're saved by faith we're judged by
works and so today there's an emergency call
answer it come out i'm not you come out of the
churches that do not respect the law of god
regardless of whatever else they say now if you
come to the adverse church are we overrun with
saints i never said that but you don't join
a church based on how well the people dress
you join it based on does it preach thus said
the lord and so in john 6 when many disciples
left christ john 6 66 he turned to the twelve
and said will he also go away and peter said
lord where shall we go thou has the words
of eternal life what kept those men truth
i was a catholic i wanted to be a priest
until my mother found out and she yanked me
out and i never stopped thanking her
i hope to see you in the resurrection
she found out the priest had his eyes on me to
make me a priest i was an altar boy i served a
priest on the altar and i felt very proud of my
my gown and white and red and i felt like a saint
and the priest said you know you have you have
potential to be a priest and my mother said
and she stopped us from going to church and
she found out that god had a holy day called
the sabbath found the night for this church
took us to it and my only regret is that i
wasn't born into it but you accept what you
have and you thank god that light has come
someone listening to me needs to make a decision
to leave that sunday honoring church and come
where truth is taught when the rich young ruler
came to christ let me finish i have to finish
he said yet lack is thou what one thing sell
all that thou hast and distribute unto the
poor and thou shalt have treasure in heaven
and come follow me one thing you lack for
many listening to me you've got one thing
you're lacking change your day of worship
from man made to god made for someone
else you remind me of the scribe
in mark 12 jesus said thou art not far from the
kingdom of god you're close make one change the
day you're close this is not salvation by words
this is love expressed in obedience you are close
don't get so close and be lost make a decision i
tell you to come out of any church that does not
honor the law of god because honoring his law is
his will for us wherever you're online you don't
have to discuss it in order to make the decision
you make the decision make it then announce it
to your husband or your wife or your children or
your mother you make the decision and then say god
i have chosen in accordance with this
emergency call come out of her my people
because jesus said in john 10 10 10 16 other
sheep i have which a lot of this fold them also
i must bring so he's bringing you don't fight
him come is there anyone in this congregation
who needs to make that decision can i see your
hand lord let me come to where the truth is taught
the comma god bless you god bless i want his name
written down on something where is the where is
the name writer someone right brother's name
god loves him someone move fast and get his name
and i'm not leaving this
place until we have his name
okay here's someone okay
someone else make a decision
come to where the truth is taught obey god god
wants to save you but he cannot save you in error
someone else father i'm answering this call i need
to come out now someone is saying i am afraid i
have this problem i have this obstacle jesus
says the things that are impossible with men
are possible with god first john 5 3 this is love
that we keep his commandments and his commandments
are not grievous or hard they are not this is
hard god will change it someone else father
there is fear in my heart that i'm making the
choice to come out probation will not be opened
forever when god closed the door of the ark those
outside couldn't get in and those inside were safe
somewhere online make that decision someone was
born again or fmc make that choice to obey this
emergency call and come out of a system where
error is the way of life come where the truth
is taught where god's church is identified is all
over the world and it defends the law of god as
a standard of righteousness not an instrument of
salvation let's pray our father in heaven i didn't
mean to go so long if i offended you forgive me
but i want us to say so much on this final day
their father there's someone listening to me
now who's fighting the conviction the person is
fighting it how can i do this but father through
your spirit reach that person help him or her to
understand and i believe in my heart it's a her
to understand that time is running out please
god reach that person please if you truly mean it
when you say you're not willing to then you should
perish reach that person father make that person
miserable until that decision is made to come out
father and for those who decided bless them
with strength because the devil has already
begun to make plans to discourage them in the
name of jesus they god take my weak effort for
the weak effort but multiply its effect that
many more decisions may be made bless the rest
of this service father take all the glory and
hasten the day when we live in a world where
everything will be righteous and according to
your will i pray from my heart in jesus name amen
the word of god says that there is joy in
heaven over one sinner one soul that repents
today we have 12 individuals
who have made a decision to
give their lives to jesus even
in baptism and i'm gonna call sister
jan to come and to read the names
and we're gonna ask that you coming to the front
of our church to present you before the church
michael gone
lisa
hazel nelson
corey millions
thank you we have gone through the vows with
them and we had a vow for the younger folks
and welfare adults in a way that they
could understand they have all said i do
and so at this time is there a motion that we
go through this process of amen is the second
dead amen amen i am going to lay hands suddenly on
the normal where she they had elder first missouri
city church and asked her if she would come and do
a prayer blessing on these candidates for baptism
let us spray father in the name of jesus we
come in humility thanking you lord for your
words that have gone forth to your people i'm
standing before this congregation today lord or
men and women who have decided that
they're going to follow you all the way
they have decided lord to make it
public by baptism so holy father
may your holy spirit even now descend and
bless them so lord when they get down in
that water and come up they will see you anew
and we say lord i have decided no matter what
i'm going to go with you all the way amen
bless their family lord may they be an example
so that the family looking on will say
truly i've seen a change in their life
and those who are not committed to you let
lord they will decided i'm gonna do so too
lord we ask that you will
continue to bless the speaker yes
and help lord that as he go over
the world and proclaim your word
that these would be words that truly follow what
the bible said preach the gospel amen to the world
keep those of us lord who have made
this decision some time ago faithful
may we be an example to the
new ones who are coming on
may they see your lives lord and say i want
to be like that person bless us now we pray
keep us all faithful in the name
of jesus amen amen amen amen
thank you this time you will go and prepare for
baptism uh again special thanks to eldesquit
for presenting the word over the last two weeks
and let us keep the word going let's keep sharing
the good news and you can go online and get the
sermons and watch them and share them with your
loved ones again thanks to pastor godwin for
preparing the candidates for baptism i'm going
to ask if sister yvonne and her team can come
up and sing some hymns as we prepare for baptism
we would start with number 535
five two five
okay okay we're saying we'll change that one we've
seen number 336 there's a fountain
filled with blood three three six
336.
is
day
my
is
shall never lose
ready
for me
me
is
amen number six twenty six two zero
i
oh
christmas
is
foreign
and all the time we're about to witness a ceremony
required of us by god and as the bible says
those who are baptized have put on christ
baptism is also a symbol of dying to the
past and rising to newness of life the water
doesn't convert you the decision is already made
it is an awkward symbol of an internal change that
has taken place and i believe we're ready for the
very first before we do let's pray our father
in heaven we thank you so much that you have
called us to participate in this service as this
service continues father let your spirit be very
intimately present a god that your name may be
glorified your people blessed and others may
be inspired to make the same decision i pray in
jesus name amen our first child of god corey lee
millions
the bible says suffer the
little children to come unto me
and forbid them not timothy is a child he knew
the scriptures which were able to make him wise
through faith unto salvation christ as a
little boy was in the temple talking to doctors
and the doctors could not answer his
questions we thank god for the corey
we had the privilege of baptizing corey's mom
a few months ago and yesterday
corey celebrated his birthday
and corey is very excited about giving his life
to jesus i mean giddy excited and i praise god
for his passion and his love for god amen and
so corey on the profession of your faith in
jesus christ i now baptize you in the name of the
father and of the son and of the holy ghost amen
what do you say church amen amen god is good
our next candidate is nias ambrose
ambrose thank you brother nice ambrose
tight
has been attending baytown church for a
while he has gone through the bible study
classes that i could have been conducting
and nias was ready to give his life to jesus
and we praise god when young folks make this
decision because they can be doing all kinds
of stuff but the fact that he loves jesus
and wants to give his life completely to god
i praise god for that and so now nia is on
the profession of your faith in jesus christ
i now baptize you in the name of the father
and of the son and of the holy ghost amen
what do you say church amen amen god bless
our next candidate is carlos geiner
carlos where's carlos oh there he is
in the sweet by and by we shall lead on
that beautiful show in the swede by and by
we shall meet on that beautiful
show all right we just had a slip but nothing
catastrophic happened we thank god for that
our brother carlos is a member here at baytown
the port church after listening to the sermons
after sermon he has decided that he needs to
rededicate his life to jesus even in baptism
we praise god for our brother and so on
the profession of your faith in jesus
i now baptize you in the name of the father
and of the son and of the holy ghost amen
amen all right that's someone who's
eager to get baptized god bless him
sing them over again to me
wonderful worlds of life
let me more of the beauty see wonderful words
dale thorpe is our next words of life and beauty
teach me faith and duty beautiful words
wonderful words wonderful words of life beautiful
words wonderful words wonderful words of love
beautiful words wonderful words wonderful words
our brother dale thorpe came to us
as a person that just came to us we didn't reach
out to him he came to us he came out he came out
he said after studying the word he knew that
this place was the place the right place to be
and so we praise god for him and his passion
for god i see brother thorpe as an evangelist
carrying the message around baytown and so my
dear brother on the profession of your faith in
jesus christ i now baptize you in the name of the
father and of the son and of the holy ghost amen
amen there's a land that is fairer than day
how do you pronounce this
michael ghana show in the swede by and
by we shall meet on that beautiful show
the water's cold but the arms of
jesus are warm god bless you michael
so today we're baptizing michael his sister lily
and his mom lisa and we praise god for this family
and michael's love for god his passion for god
he's always excited and i watched him grow even
during vacation bible school and so michael
on a profession of your faith in jesus christ
i now baptize you in the name of the father
and of the son and of the holy ghost amen
amen
lily lily
goner o the fullness of
redemption pledge of endless life
me
and so in obedience to the command of god as the
bible says suffer the little children to come on
to me and so lily has made this decision to give
her life to jesus and we praise god for that
and so lydia on the profession
of your faith in jesus i
now baptize you in the name of the father
and of the son and of the holy ghost amen
amen amen
sylvia rodriguez
um
hold tight hold tight
our dear sylvia loves the lord
you can feel her passion for the lord in fact
she brought her daughter-in-law and her mom here
to church so not only has she come to christ
but she's already bringing people to christ
and we praise god for that and so my dear sister
on the profession of your faith in jesus christ
i now baptize you in the name of the father
and of the son and of the holy ghost amen
amen
sherry
breath mcneill love o the fullness of
redemption pledge of endless life above
step carefully okay
wrap your thumb around that's right that's
right good hold tight our dear sister sherry
also came in fact she called me one day and asked
if our church was open because she had come at 9
15 and the church was closed and so i told her
what time that we were starting at 9 45 and when
i pulled up at 9 45 she was here we praised god
for that she had been studying on our own and
came to this adventist truth and so we praise god
that she has made this decision today to give her
life to jesus even in baptism and so today on
the profession of your faith in jesus christ
i now baptize you in the name of the father
and of the son and of the holy ghost amen
amen
hazel nelson
i plunged cleanseth me oh praise the lord it
cleanseth me it cleanseth me yes cleanse of me
tell her to step carefully
hold on to that rails praise the lord
sister nelson we praise god for
your commitment for your decision
to give your life to jesus i think she may
be my cousin but we'll figure that out we
and so today on the profession
of your faith in jesus christ
i now baptize you in the name of the father
and of the son and of the holy ghost amen
amen amen
sharon woodstock
go
we have sharon and trish together
daughter mother and daughter amen
we praise god for sharon's
decision to give her life to jesus
but we also thank god for trish's influence
and the example that she said and so
sharon has made a decision to give her life
and trish is recommitting her life to god
even in baptism and so now sharon on the
profession of your faith in jesus christ
i now baptize in the name of the father
and of the son and of the holy ghost amen
amen now trish his child and forever i am
redeemed reading by the blood of the lamb reading
and so trish as you've made this decision
to recommit yourself to god even in baptism
we praise god for this decision and we know
that because of this god will bless you and
grow you and make you prosperous for him and so
on the profession of your faith in jesus christ
i now baptize in the name of the father and
of the son and of the holy ghost amen amen
emily
along with the lord i shall be ready
redeemed read him by the blood of the lamb
redeem
greedy
me young ellie has also made this decision
from a very early age to give her life to jesus
to surrender herself to god in service and so
we thank god for her decision we praise god
we join heaven and rejoicing and so on the
profession of your faith in jesus christ i
now baptize you in the name of the father
and of the son and of the holy ghost amen
amen amen
lisa garner
jesus said
we have with us sister lisa and lisa has made this
decision to renew recommit rededicate herself to
god even in baptism and we praise god for people
who come to the place where they realize that they
need a closer walk they need more of jesus in
their lives and so as she makes this decision
on the profession of your faith in jesus christ
i now baptize you in the name of the father
and of the son and of the holy ghost amen
amen
uh
amen you have witnessed what god has asked us to
do and we have obeyed him and god always honors
obedience someone else needs to make a similar
decision to give that life to christ through
baptism and as i make this appeal if that
person is you make it public who else needs
to make a decision to follow christ in baptism
and say i love you i want to do what's right
god bless you god bless you my sister god bless
you from the foundation of my heart and i believe
i speak for god thank anybody else you may be
online ah we're in the back we're in the back we
have a handsome brother a son of god god bless you
we'll get those two names we have yours already
we'll get his anyone else ah god bless you god
bless you god bless you who took the names earlier
when i made the first call someone took the names
who was that a nice lady took the name where
is she plea okay do you know you go all the good
good god good girl or anybody else this is serious
this is serious you know there's something
called procrastination procrastination is an
expression of arrogance here's what i mean your
teacher tells you i want the homework by monday
you decide i'll do it by tuesday because you have
said i will live to see tuesday are you with me
you may not procrastination is based on arrogance
i have decided i'll be alive on thursday so i'll
put off monday's work for thursday never do
that whenever you've got a decision to make
make it at the earliest opportunity so god bless
you god bless you and god bless you anybody else
anybody else i need to make this where ah a child
of god god bless you where's my sister you see
that you see okay god bless you and online make
the decision those of you online those are born
again make that decision let us know those at fmc
make that decision there is power in a decision
we thank god for this day can you say amen
again all right let's borrow heads and pray
but before we uh before we pray let's sing
one stance up something please stand with me
let's sing there's power in the blood is that
okay my lovely sister just one stanza of power
in the blood 294 i believe it is 294 294 yes
i want you to sing as though god is listening
because he is and as though you
believe there's power in the blood
singing would you be free from the burden of sin
this power in the blood power in the blood were
there's wonderful power in the blood there's
power wonder working power in the glory
in the precious blood of the lamb now by the
grace of our lord jesus christ and the love of god
and the fellowship of the
holy spirit be with us now
and forevermore let god's people say
amen and amen at fmc this after pastor
amen thank you for your patience we just want
to do a quick presenting of the new members
of born again of baytown laporte and our first
missouri city seventh day adventist church to
the church and ask that we have a vote to accept
them into our membership we have some presence
that we also want to give
to the children especially
no that one is for corey yeah right fiona
that's for cory right okay so corey come on up
amen
yes yes stand right here please
and lily is lydia ready yet
michael come come on michael
okay come on lily
okay
um corey corey
amen
okay no she's in the restroom
hazel nelson
yes
sherry
sylvia rodriguez
and we'll call miss sharon is
sharon still back there all right
charlie charlie should be done by now
okay
okay so is there a motion that we accept them into
the membership of she is in the restroom so yeah
you know we'll go into the membership of baytown
laporte born again and first missouri city send
the adventist church second dead all in favor
say aye these are all the people that love you
and welcome you into our fellowship may god bless
you thank you for coming may god bless you and
keep you safe we will be meeting this afternoon
at first missouri city church at 6 00 p.m the
time change 6 p.m at first missouri city church
for a time of question and answer come on ellie
okay so we're going to ask pastor ski to offer
prayer and we'll sing one verse of 6 33 as we go
in acts chapter 2 verse 37 verse 38 the bible
says now when they heard this they were pricked
in their heart and said unto peter unto the rest
of the apostles men and brethren what shall we do
here's what peter said repent and be baptized
every one of you in the name of jesus christ
for the remission of sins and you have
done that here's how the verse ends
and ye shall receive the gift of the
holy ghost god cannot lie what i want
to do now is ask god since they fulfill
their part of the bargain we want him to
fulfill his beginning right now so wherever
you can kneel with me as i offer this prayer
father in heaven we come to you in obedience to
your word your word says repent they've done that
be baptized they've done that for the
remission of sins you have done that
then your word concludes this
way ye shall receive the gift
of the holy ghost in the name of jesus christ who
is truth father because you yourself are truth
and the holy ghost you'll give is truth
grant them a measure of your spirit right
now where they are their god don't wait because
delay is deadly give them a measure of your
spirit now and with that measure of your spirit
their god let them decide on you that they will
represent you wherever they go that they will live
by the truth they have learned and all their lives
there will be faithful seventh-day adventists and
no power on earth will move them bless them their
god and use them to lead others to the truth thank
you for your love thank you for christ bless the
remainder of today's activities i pray in jesus
name let god's people say amen and amen you